good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can stay
inspired and keep going as you watch the
video if there's something that someone
says that really deeply resonates with
you make sure as always to leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well you know you're a craftsperson you
want to produce exponential results you
want to WoW all witnesses you want to
really be the leader in your field and
it all starts with being inspired I mean
I used to be a litigation lawyer I used
to think the idea of inspiration was
very soft it was all about hard tactics
strategy execution and yet if you look
at Elon Musk and you look at Nelson
Mandela you look at Jeff Bezos so you
look at habló Picasso you look at any
game changer legendary performer what
they did was because they were inspired
I mean if you look at Elon Musk right
now with SpaceX that's coming from
inspiration if you look at the work of
da Vinci he was inspired you look at
Thomas Edison inspiration if you look at
a lot of these startups these are women
and men doing what they want to do
because they are fueled by this intense
purpose but at the foundation of the
purpose is inspiration and so
inspiration is not sort of important
inspiration is fundamentally important
and will not quit in the universe you
will keep going in your business you may
move but you will not stop will not quit
you will keep going I also told my wife
you booked this this this disease will
not defeat us this disease will not
break us it will make us better and
everybody knows my family knows that we
took a chronic illness
we took a chronic illness and we took
our marriage to another level
we took a part of illness and beat it
and we will continue to beat it until we
destroy it that's it the doctor like
that I said do it she said she has to do
it every day I said ok how long she said
every day for the rest of her life I
said I will not accept that there are
things in your life that you are
accepting because I actually got
accepted I don't care you adopted I will
not accept that we do not we will not
shoot her with will we will not give her
a shot with that needle every single day
for the rest of our life
three months later I got the call that
says that now this little shorter and
you only have to do it three times a
week as opposed to every day that's what
I told them I stopped grateful I still I
still do think that because it's only
gonna be excited I will not accept it
stop accepting everything stop letting
people tell you what you can and cannot
do I will not accept it I don't care
you're a doctor I do not accept it you
know how about pill that you can take
because I guess what we need we need to
peel the peel
on your dream I went to the doctor she
said I would have told you about it but
uh I don't think your insurance
company's gonna be willing to pay for it
two thousand dollars a month
hundred thousand dollar year sure it's
called me tonight if I went back the
second time they denied so might stop
any a 121 you do $2,000 a month look
like you're $120,000 now to get for a
year I will not I will not let my life
whatever it takes I will not let her
take the I will get 120 I will spit more
I get better I will get degrees I will
get training I'll do whatever it takes I
will put your health first and it will
not be defeated you will not be
destroyed you will not lose a king will
not be in a wheelchair we will be this
some of you in this room you are not
able to activate your greatness because
every time the trial and tribulation
comes it's all tell you you take it
personal
every time somebody tells you don't have
what it takes you embrace it and now you
gotta stand up to it I never did one
time of my life I never felt discouraged
I never felt that it was impossible my
wife told me just a couple days ago it
says today I feel before I got in this
she had a weekend where she felt great
and I told her it's for began to gain
some
for the rest of your life it will not
break it will not retreat will not give
up will activate our greatness and we
won't know what it's like to live the
ones wanna say I will come on if you
make up your mind you're gonna live to
120 I went from being homeless even out
the trash cans traveling first class
hundred thousand dollars in engagement
back at home every stop NBA NFL whatever
I consult them ii didn't say if you want
to be more inspired nature one of my
favorite pop protocols is the daily
nature walk I love walking in the woods
I often listen to audiobooks in the
woods
I call it walk reading while walking
reading while walking so I go to this
place it's sort of my creative forest
there's not a lot of people in there and
I walk for one hour I breathe in the air
I look at the lush scenery I listen to a
different audiobook I it's almost like
walking meditation as well sometimes I
don't listen to an audio book and I just
walk and I touched the earth it's almost
like I'm thanking the earth connecting
with the soil yes I'm wearing shoes I
don't want to get too esoteric here but
there's a lot of really good research
saying if you want to boost your immune
system you want to boost your happiness
you want to release serotonin dopamine
you want to release the fear hormone
called cortisol walk in nature and so
when I walk I connect with nature and
like I say I know I'm not being very
elegant in this mastery session I'm just
being real by listening to audio books
and then other times I do a walking
meditation where I feel my feet on the
soil you know what I do other times if
there's something I'm confused about I
sort of just talk it out it's like I'm
talking out loud trying to work it
out if I'm in pain I get the negative
negative energy out of my system by just
releasing it by talking about it I also
and I know this is a little unorthodox
but I I do like a a walking blessing
meditation so while I'm walking I
started to challenge myself to come up
with 50 things I'm grateful for and
again I verbalize those because it's
only me and the squirrels in the it's
hoping me and the squirrels in the woods
and so I say I'm grateful for my family
I'm grateful for my health I'm grateful
for work that feeds my soul I am
grateful for the Sun set I watched last
night I'm grateful for my team I'm
grateful for my business I'm grateful
for the travels that I get to take I'm
grateful for the people that I've served
and literally while I'm walking I say
out loud I am grateful for I hope it
doesn't sound strange for you because
it's an incredible protocol to install
setbacks allow us to sit our us down and
scratch our head to say what am i doing
we don't want to do that we spend most
of our time getting away from ourselves
so what's helped me along my journey is
to actually see setbacks as a way the
universe is telling me how about a semi
ass down because what we often think as
Alan has an unfortunate event
as an unfortunate event could be a
blessing in disguise
slow motion away I had two laptops blow
up in front of me not nice I had to buy
new ones but actually the newer ones I
go are a lot better faster seven day
vegan challenge alert I had a lot of
setbacks growing up sometimes I would
say gosh why aren't I in that place why
aren't I
where I want to be in the perfect career
and you see how the law of attraction
works is that we attract what we are
energetically to us so look at it like
this if you have a setback or a massive
disappointment what is gonna happen you
are now gonna start mirroring back that
same energetic vibration so if you're
feeling really grumpy because of a
setback create snowball effect you're
gonna be more grumpy more grumpy more
grumpy and it's even gonna be a greater
set back to you so you've got to become
an alchemist which the secret of alchemy
is making the best out of the worst when
you fall down and not allowing external
events to govern your internal condition
and I know you've heard this but my
question is how much do you do it and
that is visually visualization and we
call it highly engaged visualization
visualization where you're seeing
yourself doing something and you're
emotive ly there you're literally
closing your eyes and meditating on the
experience you're seeing it feeling it
sensing it and it's not the kind of
visualization you've probably been
taught to do which is just all the
buoyant victory everything's great
victory hey everything's awesome perfect
it's the visualization where you also
imagine see and feel the struggle on
purpose let me give an example lots of
people when there
new too you know performance training
and never had a lot of experience they
would say oh wait you know if you're
gonna run a marathon
imagine yourself crossing that vision
and finish line you know your arms up
and victory everything is great you
cross that finish line there's your
family and they give you big hugs and
you feel great still vital energized
ready to kick some butt you know you
could run another 20 miles you're you're
the strongest most powerful you ever
know I'm like wow you know that's just a
person who hasn't done a lot of training
or actual high performance coaching in
their life because the better thing to
imagine is what happens at Mile 13 to
imagine yourself running to starting
running running strong but also seeing
and sensing and feeling yourself at Mile
13 when that decision point comes to
want to quit that's where I want you to
also enter the scene and visualize
seeing yourself struggle like seeing the
perspiration seeing the heartache seeing
the hurt the pain that like I can't run
anymore dude seeing yourself make a
decision at that point to be resilient
to keep at it to see the charge come
back on your face to see yourself
working through the struggle is the most
important visualization you can do what
would you say to yourself when it sucks
not just see yourself validated it's
about look the real truth of achieving
any dream is that struggle that effort
that push and I know you know this so my
question is when is the last time you
just gave yourself a few moments free
away from you know playing on the phone
free away from the internet just to sit
down by yourself to visualize and
daydream about your dreams about the
activities involved in that about how
you would struggle through about what it
would feel like to be victorious all of
it the whole thing the messy part the
ugly part what would you say to yourself
when it gets hard that's what you need
to do to truly actualize a dream we got
to begin with seeing it and sensing it
the good the bad the easy the difficult
and the victory you know I actually
recently I went into a coffee shop and I
was having a
particularly bad day I don't even know
why maybe I slept bad maybe things
weren't going right maybe I was losing
faith that I would reach my health and
my life goals and I talked to the girl
behind the counter and she said to me
you know I said to her how do you have
so much energy and she said you know
what was weird I actually only slept 3
and a half hours last night she had to
open up the shop at 5 a.m. she ever won
it till 5 p.m. on a few Houston and I
said why didn't you just sleep more what
are you thinking getting up at 4:00 3:30
in the morning she said honestly I got
pregnant at 16 I have three kids they
have to go to school they have to be
watched and after I get off here at 5
p.m. I have to go to another job at
Dunkin Donuts after I you know it was
funny I never heard her once complained
she had up days and down days but she
never once complained to me almost never
did she complain about being tired so we
and a half hours of sleep some nights
because she had to go from one job to
the next
because she had two young kids and she
was maybe 21 or 22 and you know you
better believe that that shut myself up
pretty quickly after she'd been doing
this for so many years sleeping half
maybe 1/3 hours i sleep I sleep seven
hours she's got the half of that
Malthus dick just doing whatever it took
and this is just to remind you that if
you're having a bad day a bad week about
month of that year guess what your
problems are probably this big compared
to most of humanity's if you're sleeping
four hours a night you've got multiple
kids your health is crap your parents
are dead or dying yeah everything is
going wrong then maybe you have a little
reason to complain but don't forget
there are billions of people in the
other parts of the world who don't
complain one ounce and all they have to
do is walk all they have to do walk five
miles to get a friggin cup of water
that's money and has kuehni most of your
big problems are nothing their first
full pump their champagne problems
compared to almost everyone else and I'm
talking specifically I'm referring to
Americans in our country but even the
poor in this country she was an example
she may say a damn word
now one complaint out of her mouth and
it's still natural if things aren't
going well is complain if you're having
an off day
listen it's totally natural so my take
on staying inspired and keep going is
that you have to one beyond the mission
and to love the work and it's something
that we've talked about over and over
and over again on the channel but for me
the thing that gets me up and and going
to work in helping entrepreneurs every
day is because it fuels me it's like
oxygen for me it's food for me I love it
I need to do it it's an obsession it's a
drug and you need to find that thing for
you and you need to find the thing that
you would do even if you weren't getting
paid for the thing that you would go
find part-time jobs to make money just
so you can focus on doing this thing
because you love it so much that's the
thing that you need to devote as much
time as possible to because that's where
you're gonna have impact that's where
you're going to have magic that's we're
going to come alive that's where you're
ultimately going to make a lot of money
as well as make a big impact and it's
not just about you can force yourself to
do something for so long before it just
falls off because you're not deeply
passionate about it you can listen to
you know a motivational speaker yelling
at you to do something and give it your
all and go for it and this is your day
you know
you can do that and
may help you for a short amount of time
but if at the core you don't enjoy what
you're doing you're not feeling like
you're contributing to the world somehow
you're not excited to wake up and go do
the work that you need to go and do I
hate long weekends because it takes me
away from my work because that's a
Monday that is off or a Friday that is
off that could be used to further the
mission that I'm on and so all of this
other stuff definitely helps you have in
the environment having the habits having
the routine you know how you set
yourself up what you listen to and what
you read and what you look at but at the
core has to be that you're doing
something that you feel is meaningful to
you and will have an impact and has
value to you because if you only have a
goal and you don't enjoy the process if
you're telling yourself I'll do anything
I need to do just to hit that goal and
you don't enjoy the work then you're
never gonna hit that goal and it'll be a
really shallow and hollow experience for
you where the people who achieve at the
highest levels they have big goals it's
great to have goals that helps you to
have goals but you have to enjoy the
work to get to that goal as well and in
my view that's how you stay inspired and
keep going
so thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kevin sjj
personal transformation requested it so
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in the next addition to believe life
leave it down the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what did you think of the video
what point resonated the most with you
what change you're gonna make now in
your life or in your business after
watching some of these clips leave it
down below writing it down
helped cement it for you when you have
an idea of a change and you write it
down you're much more likely to follow
through so hopefully we can help do that
for you as well by you commenting below
I'm also going to join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon
there is great value in just getting out
there my friend Tom Peters talked about
it years ago he called it managing by
walking around and he he spoke of it in
the context of within an organization
leave your office and just walk around
but I see it as even larger with all due
respect to Tom Peters who is a wonderful
wonderful guru and I just want to sort
of maybe I'm the best way to say this
just take it into a different context
which is circulate around the world I
don't always love travelling I travel a
lot sometimes before it's speaking tour
I ask myself do I really want to get on
this speaking tour and then I remind
myself the power of circulation by
getting on an airplane I meet new people
by getting into a new city I get
provoked by new insights by hearing new
conversations I get new levels of energy
and so there's great power in
circulating I guess to be really
tactical what I'm encouraging you if you
want to be inspired get out there I had
a conversation just the other day with
an uber driver he was telling me how he
lived in Kiev and he became a he studied
engineering we talked about the culture
in the Ukraine but he explained why he's
now in this country he explained his
adversity story how difficult it is he
said you know what I want to be an
engineer but I've got a family to feed
so I'm doing this as an uber driver I
don't really love it by you know it's
it's it's how I make my living and we
had this conversation where I got all of
these different different ideas that
really were valuable to me so
conversations are very educating but the
point really is number one point insight
number one there's great power in
circulating because that's when you have
new conversations that's when you detect
new insights I mean I see get some of my
best ideas just reading magazines in
hotel rooms they have nothing to do with
leadership they have nothing to do with
productivity they have nothing to do
with high performance but I love reading
fashion magazines you know one of my
favorite magazines is Porter it's a new
fashion
new fashion magazine I was in Los
Angeles the other day I was reading the
rob report I was reading like it was
sort of like a style guide to Los
Angeles and just learning the languaging
of those creative people the chefs and
the fashion models and the fashion
designers and the people who are
creating these cool scenes creates great
ideas for me to bring to you so there's
great power in circulation you don't
believe the message unless you believe
the messenger so as leaders we have to
stand for and demonstrate and show and
portray what we are really believing it
I mean are we really are there is our
team and the people around us seeing us
work for it sweat for it sacrifice for
it champion over and over and over again
even when it's hard even when there's
conflict even when people are pissed
even when people want to quit are you
still there do you still stand for if
you do you'll become a legend and I
found two things out about smart people
I think it's almost impossible for a
smart person to win in business in
America today because I find smart
people spend their whole lifetime
figuring things out they always trying
to figure out an easier way in a quicker
way and another thing I found out about
smart people's they just don't get
around to doing nothing they see
somebody like art Williams everybody
said well he can't do it and some
I can't do it but he does it see folks I
want you to know almost everybody in
America almost does enough to win they
almost get there they almost over the
hump they almost have it going they
almost and everything they do almost is
a way of life to almost everybody in
America but the winners do it what do
they do they do whatever it takes to get
the job done they do it and do it and do
it and do it and do it until the job
gets done and then they talk about how
great it is to be somebody they're proud
of we need leaders in America who can do
it if you want to become somebody do it
if you want to go in business for
yourself do it if you want to become
financially independent do it I hear too
much talk in these United States
everybody can talk a good game we need
people in America who can do it I go all
over this country with Al weaves and I
have people say aren't you you count on
me
wonderful just do it all right guarantee
this is my light last stop I'm gonna win
now SuperDuper just do it all right if I
could just have one good month and get
the ball going I know I could make it
big super just do it my heart if I could
just pay off this debt I could really go
great
just do it hard if I could just sell my
house do it but house they selling do it
anyway
I'm not making any money what can I do
you just do it let's do what art you do
it and do it and do it all right can't
you have a win this contest super duper
just do it I'm over the hump now watch
my smoke grades just do it I don't wanna
make it so bad I can taste it what I do
you just do it all right I'm a vice
president now can I quit doing it no all
right I don't know if I keep on keeping
on I really heard what I do you just do
it do what are you do it and do it and
do it all right all my life I want to be
somebody important we would do it then
oh that won't save money so I don't have
to go through this again
great hey just do it all right I don't
feel like I've had enough training what
I do you just do it all right I'm here
as you don't give me no help what I do
you just do it all right you don't
understand I was mr. everything in my
former company you don't mean I have to
start down at the bottom and do it do
you yep you really got to do it
Bart what's the primary difference
between winners and losers the winner
the winners do it they do it and do it
and do it and do it until the job gets
done and then they talk about how great
it is to finally achieve something you
need and how glad they are that they
didn't quit like everybody else and how
wonderful it is to finally be somebody
they're proud of and make a difference
with their life